parti au cours de ces dernières années
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur patrick hetzel pour le groupe
l'est républicain le premier ministre le
haut conseil de la famille vient de
publier une note sur le développement de
l'accueil des jeunes enfants
les ambitions de votre gouvernement sont
loin d'être au rendez vous la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion signé entre la
branche famille et l'état prévoyait la
création 275 milles sur lui choqué selon
le rapport sur les deux premières années
de la convention seulement 19% des
objectifs création de solutions
d'accueil ont été atteints par votre
gouvernement en 2014
onze mille trois cents places d'accueil
collectif ont été créés contre 19600
prévu s'agissant de l'accueil individuel
la baisse poursuit avec 612 mille
enfants de moins de 3 ans accueillis par
des assistantes maternelles en 2014
contre 619 1400 en 2013 soit près de
7000 tout petits 2 - prise en charge
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de votre
gouvernement
l'objectif de 20 mille enfants
supplémentaires accueillis par an
s'éloigne évidemment de plus en plus le
nombre d'employeurs d'assistantes
maternelles baisse également 2014 et il
ya en plus graves
le volume d'heures déclarées recul de
façon marquée en 2014 après déjà une
diminution en 2013 le constat est le
même pour la gare inde au domicile des
parents comment ne pas y voir les camps
ce logique des multiples coups de rabots
apportée par votre gouvernement aux
statuts du particulier employeur au
cours des dernières années les
difficultés que rencontrent les parents
ne font qu'empirer la pression sur les
modes de garde sera pire encore dans un
an quand la réforme du congé parental
aura pris toute son ampleur
vous l'aurez compris le compte n'y est
vraiment pas en monsieur le premier
ministre
qu avez-vous l'intention de proposer
pour enfin venir en aide à nos familles
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
madame la secrétaire d'état à la famille
et à l'enfance vous avez la parole
madrid tente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur députée aysel d'abord
je vous remercie du soutien que vous
nous apportez en faisant de l'accueil
des jeunes enfants une priorité une
priorité collective et j'espère que ce
soit aussi une priorité des communes et
des collectivités locales à cette
priorité était donnée par le président
de la république dès le début de son
mandat est effectivement notre nos
engagements sont faibles 2 75011 places
de crèche places d'accueil
supplémentaires
cent mille places en crèche cent mille
places les accents de maternelle et
75000 accueille des jeunes enfants de
moins de 3 ans en préscolarisation ses
objectifs aujourd'hui après deux années
qui sont des ânes électorat pas des
années pendant lesquelles les communes
investissent dans des équipements
nouveaux
c'est assez de nos chiffres se redresse
puisque cette année avec 14300 berceau
supplémentaire c'est trente sept mille
enfants qui pourront être accueillis
cette année en d'enos d'équipements
collectifs pour jeunes enfants et ainsi
que dans l'est la préscolarisation c'est
30% des enfants qui sont accueillants
jeune rural en zone rurale à ce propos
j'invite les parents à davantage
utiliser investir cet accueil
pédagogique adapté au rythme de l'enfant
spécifiques à ces besoins qui se
développe aujourd'hui avec de
l'éducation nationale en ce qui concerne
les récentes maternelle je vous concède
que nous constatons en effet que les
instants maternelle recevoir - enfants
accueillent moins d'enfants et avec elle
nous travaillons actuellement à faire
évoluer
l'accueil des jeunes enfants chez lui à
sion de maternelle l'adapter besoins qui
sont pas le même dans tous les quartiers
il ya des quartiers dans lesquels il y a
beaucoup de centres maternels et moins
d'enfants et des quartiers dans lesquels
au contraire il y à beaucoup d'enfants
accueillir et moins d'enfants de
maternelle
l'évolution est dans l'innovation
sociale la souplesse adaptation nous
tiendrons ses engagements et merci
encore de remarquer que la politique
familiale française
c'est d'abord et avant tout la qualité
modes d'accueil
merci madame